- [Narrator] All right, Sharky.
Do you, do you live here in Skid row?
- Yes, I do.
- [Narrator] Where are you at?
I'm on a lot right now.
And I'm back and forth
from Crocker and Stanford.
- [Narrator] You're in a tent?
- Yeah, I'm in a tent, yeah.
- [Narrator] How long
have you been down here?
- I've been down here, I say.
Like five years.
Going back and forth from regard to park.
From here to magenta park to Ontario, back
it's a lot.
- [Narrator] Yeah.
- Yeah.
Now the whole reason why I'm homeless
is because I stole from my
brother-in-law, you know.
- [Narrator] You stole from her?
- My brother-in-law, my brother-in-law.
- [Narrator] your brother-in-law.
- Yeah, I stole the gun
and we went all bad.
And.
He, and like,
it all started, like I with
and I was with some girl.
And I was working.
I've got out of work.
I went to go see this girl..
This girl was getting high.
And I wasn't getting high at the time.
And then she's like, Why you ain't high,
why you ain't high?"
Then I'm, "I'm good, I'm good, I'm good."
Shut up with shit, you know.
And then I was like, fine.
I'd finally said, "Let me see it."
And I started getting
high again high again.
And I was like, "Damn."
I was like, "Damn I can't
go home now, I'm high."
But then I got into an
incident with another,
with another group of people.
As I was walking down the street.
And one of them pulled
a gun on me, you know?
And.
And I got stuck between a car and a truck.
And as soon as I turned around to run,
I ran behind the truck,
he started shooting at me.
He started shooting me, he shot about like
like six times, all, all of
them went into the truck.
I rolled underneath the truck
and he started shooting
underneath the truck.
And can I remember him shooting
from the front of the car
from the front of the truck.
And the bullets went like
it was crazy.
So I was like fuck.
I was about to step after
everything happened,
I took it right, we left.
I was thinking like, I gotta, I gotta go.
I gotta get this back, you know.
- [Narrator] Wait what?
I gotta get him back, you know.
That's what I was thinking, you know.
That was my mind at that time.
So I was just like,
so we went to my brother-in-law's
house it was late.
It was like one o'clock in the morning.
My sister was like, who's that?
And I was just like, "You
know, some girl, you know."
And she's like, "All right."
So she went to bed
and I was like I remember.
I was like the gun in the garage.
And so I was like, "I'll be back."
So I went in the garage and I just
I went in there, I pulled it out.
I was just like, I was just
chipping out, just tripping out.
Like we put the together, you know?
But.
But I ended up leaving.
I took it.
I jumped on the bus
and I remember, I remember going back
just like, it's crazy.
It was crazy in this, after that.
- [Narrator] What happened?
- A lot happened at night.
You know.
I had a lot happen at night, you know,
but
something I'll never forget.
I never forget that I went
home after everything was done.
I got rid of everything.
Everything's gone, nothing to worry about.
I get home and my brother-in-law tells me.
He come out,
He comes out and he tells me,
Just look at the car."
And I'm like "Fuck,
damn."
You know what I mean?
I guess y'all he already knew.
He already knew in his mind already would
that night that I came home,
something happened back
and he kept telling me like,
"What was wrong with you?"
I think I got it.
So he already knew like something was up.
So he didn't, I don't
think you slept that night.
Think you just heard,
just listen to me walking
around the house.
And I wouldn't leave it.
Like I said
when he caught, I came home.a
and it was like,
two days before, three days
like three days before, before Christmas
Everything's fine.
Like perfect, you know.
And then,
my brother-in-law tells me, he calls me,
"Hey Dave."
I'm like, "What?"
And he's like, "Come on,
go in the garage with me."
Let's work on the car.
And I'm like, "Fuck."
Because the first thing he does is
open the drawer to open
the little case, you know?
And he,
he opens up the toolbox
and he throws the case at me.
And he tells me "Where's it at?"
I tell him "what?"
And he's like, "Where is it at?"
And I was just like,
I don't know, like you know what I mean?
And I was like,
And he's like,
"This is Bullshit."
And I, I remember him going inside.
I'm thinking, fuck, this one.
He's going to come out and
stab me or something, you know?
But my sister was shipping
out and she was like,
"You better go run, run."
And he's like, "I'm not running.
So it happens.
It happens, you know, my fault."
But I just remember he telling him
"Tomorrow in the morning
on Christmas morning
you gotta be out of the
house by eight O'clock,
you can eat, take a shower.
By eight o'clock I want
you out of this house."
I was like, tomorrows way,
tomorrow Christmas day.
He goes, "Thanks a lot you
fucked uo for all of us."
And I was just like, "What the fuck?"
I didn't, I didn't, I
couldn't process it like that.
I had to process it like
I did this to save my life, you know.
I remember my niece telling my sister,
"Just let him stay."
And she's the,
(mumbles)
It was crazy.
But that's, that's, that's that's
that's what I became.
That's when it started.
And then I started came out,
I came into MacArthur park.
I went straight to him and
got to the park that night.
That night, she was just
like, it was just a blur.
It was just, it was, it
was party from then on.
I mean, it was just, I got down downhill.
- [Narrator] That was how many years ago?
- That's like about, I say like 34 now.
I was probably like 24, 25.
- [Narrator] You didn't get caught?
- No I was going to jail in between.
In between
In between the months and
years, as the years went by.
And I still, I was going
in and out of jail.
I was constantly in and out jail.
Fighting cases.
- [Narrator] Right.
You know what I mean?
I fought the third strike.
I fought my third strike.
I beat it.
It was just, it was,
it was chaos, you know?
And it's like--
- [Narrator] Go for what
happened on that night.
You didn't get a caught.
- No, no, I never got caught for that.
And that was, that was, I
was stressed out for that.
I didn't want to come outside.
I didn't want to do nothing.
So now I come to MacArthur park
I'm running like a wild man.
I'm running with all kinds of
different neighborhoods now.
I started, like, I started running
with a lot of like neighbors
that were around there
which I won't name their names, you know?
But,
just from, you know what I mean?
But I've seen a lot of
shit that that's crazy.
You know, a lot of shit, like lot.
But,
I think the drugs started,
like when I was like
I'm going to go back to like
when I was a kid, like drugs started as
as young as I was nine years old.
I was nine years old.
I'll never forget it.
I was kicking on my, well,
my dad's friend, my dad took
my dad, took me to, to
one of his, I guess,
drug spots I guess when
I was a kid, you know.
Because my dad used to be a heroin addict.
So I was just like, I was
like, "All right, let's go."
So we went and then like
I smelled weed, you know?
Because I used to always see a smell.
My brother brother's smoking weed.
So I,
I was standing right next to
my, my dad's friend and, and
and he was standing, he was smoking.
I smelled the weed and I
was like, "Hey, Hey man
let me hit the weed."
He was like, "You dad is here."
And he was like, "Let me get the weed."
He was like, "All right."
So let me hit the joint.
But not knowing that it
was, it had cracks in it.
So it was, it was so I was like fuck
I was like feeling a
certain weird, you know
but at same time I was cool
you know, I was like fuck.
So I went home that night.
I didn't sleep all that night.
I was like "Fuck."
Going home my mom was telling
me, "What's wrong with you?
What's wrong with you?"
Nothing, nothing.
I not there in that day.
And then the next two to three days went
by and then I got that urge.
I want to smoke.
I want to smoke with what I got.
I stole $20 from my mom out of her wallet.
And I called this, I called
the number he gave me
and I told him I want a 20.
So when he goes, "All right,
come down to the same spot."
So I went down and since Bonnie came out.
and he gives me this white rock
right with this white piece,
I thought it was chalk.
I was like, "What's this shit?"
He's like, that's what we're smoking.
And he's like, "You just put
marijuana with it or tobacco."
I was like " Fuck, you
don't have no weed."
He's like, "I'll give you some weed."
So he gave me some weed and I was rolling.
I was rolling, joints
they were all fucked up.
but I was just smoking, you know.
But I remember being
in the garage and I was
just like one after one
after the other, then it
was just like after awhile
it was like, I was like,
"What I was going into."
I was already in fifth
grade, I was in the bathroom
in the fifth grade bathroom,
hitting the foil pipe that I
made put in ashes to put the crack on top.
So it's a real trick because
I didn't have Barilla.
I was like, What?
I'm smoking crack in the
restroom in elementary, you know
when a class all cracked out, you know,
I went to class
I went to school, went to sixth.
I went to sixth, seventh and eighth.
I was already full-blown
crack head already.
By the time I was in eighth grade,
I was already smoking crack straight.
You know, it was already
like 13 years old,
just cracked out.
Running the streets,
smoking my mom's cigarettes
drinking her beer, not
listening to nothing.
She had to say, you know,
but this, by this time
I get busted, I get it.
I get into my neighborhood.
I get into my neighborhood,
like I say, like 11 and a half
And then like two weeks after that,
after I get into my neighbor hood.
So whenever I get busted, I get busted.
I get you for life.
So I didn't get out of
jail until I was 23.
So I did all, all my junior high
or high school to my dish too.
So I was 23 years old.
You know what, by this
time my dad and my I'm I'm
I'm selling him like
for like 13 years old, I'm like 13 years.
I'm like, I'm like 13 years
old and I'm sending heroin
from jail to, to my dad
on the outside, you know?
And
And I was my dad's dealer.
I was at my dad's connection
for like a lot of years, you know?
Because my dad did it
really like to meet people
that sold them heroin, you know?
So he would make me go out there
and find the good ones you know?
So I had to go out there and,
and I would be looking around
and I wouldn't be like,
"All right, you gotta go to this guy.
We gotta get this guy
on our team, you know."
So I think I'd get fucking the guy.
I've talked to him,
my dad would get kicked the mail
and he'd get all the stamp letters.
And, but this time
I get out.
For some reason, I get out
with some for some reason
I don't know what it was for.
So I'm out, for a little while.
And during this time that I'm out.
My dad gets at, my dad gets out of jail
And
My dad's like, wait, "Where are you at?"
He's like, "I thought you were busted."
I'm like, yeah, I'm out.
So I'm, I don't know how long we'd be out.
But where was the, where you at?
I said, well, "My birthday is tomorrow.
I'm in Arizona."
He said, "I'll be there tomorrow."
So don't ask me, don't
ask me how I took off.
My mom got drunk that night.
I kept feeding my mom beer.
I'll never forget it.
I was giving her, my mom,
her beer and her big old cup.
And I was getting the brandy
and I was mixing it, bro.
I was fixing that.
Here you go.
And she was just drinking cups
and she was fucked up.
I'll never forget it.
I was like, man, you're fucked up.
She couldn't even walk to the restroom.
She would fall.
She was faded.
I'll never forget.
I was laughing.
I was fucking like,
(laughing)
it was like the best time of my life.
I was like, look at what I do to you now,
got you off the up you can't even walk.
I'm like 14 years old, 15.
I was like, yeah, you
can't walk, you know.
And, and she's like, you son of a bitch,
you got me fucked up.
You up at mashing my fucking drinks.
(laughs)
So I say, yeah, so she it.
She sitting there and she
smoking her cigarette falls out.
Yeah, just ran on time.
Bam I looked at the bus schedule,
bus schedules on time.
It's like six something.
Catch the next bus at 7:56.
I fucking get there at seven 7:36.
I ran all the way from El
Salvador to city terrace
to catch a 70 bus and like 25 minutes.
That's from my mustering all
the way to see the terrace.
That's like I city over.
Made it.
I made it jumped on a 78.
Took me all the way to Las
tunas all the way to the
all the way to, to Armani bus station.
I tried to catch some gray on there.
I just told the lady I got money.
It's great.
Trying to catch gray hound.
Where are you going to Arizona?
(laughs)
They're like, well, hold you,
you got to ride with somebody.
I tell them I need a ticket.
She goes, while we're closed here
you need to wait til the
next ticket in Claremont.
But you need to ask someone
tell to say that you're writing.
Would you in order for you to go?
Cause you're not 18 years old
like, fuck man, I'm pissed.
I'm tripping out.
(laughs)
I'm tripping.
And this guy said, no, no.
Just calm down
I'll just say you're my little nephew.
And you can ride with me.
I'm like, all right, cool.
So I paid, I go out and get on a bus drive
on the gray hound right now.
And
I get off.
I pay the lady at the window and way.
He's like, Oh, you can't get on.
You don't have nobody at all.
And I told that guy right
there and he's like, Oh, okay.
So they got everything cleared, whatever.
But before we go, I'm
like, I want to get drunk.
So I go to the seven 11 that's nearby.
I tell this guy gave me
a S a seven up slushie,
cherry seven Stachy a
large one and a large Sysco
cherry cherry flavor sysco.
I pour it all in a cup.
And then we leave from clermont station
and we're on the way to Arizona
and I'm drinking and I'm drinking.
And I pass out.
I don't even know where the I'm at.
I wake up the bus drivers like wake up.
Bam, bam, bam, all that.
What the fuck?
bottle
Here I was all
fucked up, it was crazy.
It throw up over here.
I was fucked up all faded.
And, and I remember I had my
last 50 cents in my pocket.
It was my last 50 cents.
And I'm at the Phoenix bus
station I had called my mom.
because I didn't have my
brother-in-law's phone number.
I was like, mom, answer the fucking phone.
Mind you.
She thinks I'm at home.
It's like two o'clock in the morning.
I get in Arizona.
So it was like, it was like fine, like
like early morning, like
the sun barely coming up.
So I call my mom and my mom's like
hello, What the fuck?
I'm like, mom's it's fucking me.
She's like, what the fuck?
You sound like, you're a jail man.
I'm like, nah, I'm at
the Phoenix bus station.
I need brother-in-law's phone number.
Now I got two minutes on his phone.
It's going to hang up.
So if you don't give me her
number, I'm stuck out here
in the desert and I'm gonna die.
And she's like, you're not you.
You're not you're next door.
So she does three weeks.
She calls the next door neighbors.
She thinks I'm at the boy's house.
And she's like
hello. Maria asked you
Mom. And she's like, hello?
Is David over there?
No, he's not here.
That's Son of a bitch.
That motherfucker.
She's like, why?
No, no.
I'll call you back.
She hangs up butter.
You son of a bitch.
You Motherfucker.
What the fuck is your problem"
What the fuck are you doing over there?
I told you, I told you I was leaving.
And I told you I was
going to my, see my dad.
You didn't fucking believe me.
you said I was crazy right?
No, you're crazy.
I told you, I'm gone.
I told you I was going to do it.
And she's like, where'd you get the money?
I took your money out your purse,
so I'm sorry you ain't
got the money today.
She was pissed
And, and she gives me my
brother-in-law's number.
And my my dad had just got
out of prison that time.
So she was like with my brother-in-law,
because they kicked him out
of the city of Los Angeles.
My dad was just, they
called him a menace society
to city of California.
So they kicked them out of the state
and the sent him to Arizona.
They picked any other state.
You can't live here.
It's just fucking off the hook, you know.
So I swear. I think I
get it from it, you know.
I think that's where it rubs off.
So, so like, so I go
and I see him and I call him,
I'm here. I'm in Arizona.
Where's your mom at,
just started talking to my dad.
And I'm like, man, shut up, man.
I don't want to hear that shit, man.
And she's like quit cursing.
I'm fuck that I've done, you know.
I'm thinking I bad-ass, you know.
so I'm talking all kind of shit to her.
She's like, wait until you get home,
I'm going to fuck you up.
Yeah, yeah, right, yeah.
I learned than that one.
So, so mind you, this I'm on probation.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on
supervised supervision.
Fucking high control probation again gang.
I got three probations.
I got regular, I got drugs
and I got gang related
probation at all at the time.
I'm not even supposed to be state.
I take off home.
Well yeah.
Check this out.
Hello?
Yeah, he took off where'd he go?
He went to Arizona.
I can't control him anymore.
Alright, bye.
Couple days go by
brother-in-law's phone rings.
Hello
Oh shit.
There, there, at the front door
and cuffs, chains and all this.
My brother-in-law's freaking out.
My brother-in-law's not dad's time.
And obviously really knows about this.
You know, my aunt don't
even know about this.
You know this stuff too
that we've been through and grab a beer.
That's it.
When you grab up, my dad
had me cause tuck it.
My brother-in-law's hiding both of us.
You know what I mean?
My dad wasn't even supposed
to be at that address.
It's supposed to be somewhere else.
So, so my mom gets just both busted.
They take me back out to play.
They fly me back.
I'm like on the mafia playing like fuck,
I'm fucking like air con one and shit.
You know, fuck a chain that and chin
and with all kinds of
people looking at me like.
So I'm going back a
and my dad him goes to jail again.
I'm almost close to
going back to jail again.
By this time my dad comes back over here.
He gets out and he comes back
to my mom's old house and he tells me,
Hey do you have any,
you know, I'm like, nah.
And he's like, Come on man.
I'm like, dude, I don't have nothing.
I got to take these two.
I'm going to court tomorrow.
I got to take these in, you know.
I gotta take this and he's
like, come on me, hold on.
Let me get some I'm
like, nah, not this one.
And he's like, come
on, just give me three.
I know he's like, give me three.
I said three.
That's it just three.
Just give me five, five
five I don't like thinking five
the fuck you gonna do with five,
I ask him all three of
them and then do two.
And I make my money.
I'll bring it to you.
So I was like fuck
Money all right.
All right.
I'll give them to him.
And I tell him, Hey,
Be careful, you know.
I gave him, I gave him three at first
and he was like, Oh, there's three.
I said, yeah has enough.
But then that means only could do one.
And I'm like, that's it that's enough.
And he's like.
And he kept bugging and bugging
and bugging and bugging.
I'm talking.
He's like, do you have any white?
Gave him, I give him one more.
So I told him it was four
four and, I was like, yeah.
So I gave him four balloons and four.
That's it.
I was like, man, I, I told
him, I give you some weed.
But then I was like, it.
I'm just gonna throw that last five when
I'm throwing them, give them, put it
inside the weed and give it to him.
So when he opens it up, he'll
have that last one, you know.
He'll be like, Oh, he gave it to me now.
And then I remember him
calling me, telling me,
Hey Mel, I seen him.
When you left, when
you opened the weed day
I found the other, the other bloom.
And I'm like fuck.
I'm like, all right.
He's like, thank you.
And I'm like, I'm like,
you better not do them all.
And he's like, I'm not,
I see you in the morning.
I'm like, all right.
I was like, you better come home fucker.
You better come home.
And we all, I am, I am.
And I'm out of the phone.
And if I went to sleep, I
don't know why we started
the night I came home,
my mom was talking shit.
And my dad still, came home
And I was just like, what the fuck?
Why is he only called like ,the fuck?
So I go to sleep
And
Oh, no wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Before my dad died
my dad stayed at the house.
My dad, my dad
my dad's at the house, in
California, California.
He just had got out of prison
and I gave him and, and
this is, this is two days
before he gets a phone call
that my brother-in-law dies
but he's not supposed to be in California.
That's supposed to be in California.
- [Narrator] Right.
And this is in it.
He gets a phone call.
We get the phone call the next day.
And I'm telling him what the fuck?
Like my aunt calls and she's freaking out.
And fucking I'm tired.
I'm telling what the fuck,
what the fuck is going on.
So tell me, she's like
I need to talk to your mom.
You talked to your mom.
And I'm like, Tyler, what is going on?
And I I'm tripping out.
And I'm telling you, I'm not
gonna give you the phone.
And she tells me, she just
told me like your dad's dead.
I'm like, what the fuck?
It's crazy.
I was like, what do you mean?
Like, she's like, yeah, you got
to go identify him and shit.
That's crazy.
- [Narrator] He died from what?
- He died from all LD,
from the balloons that I gave him.
Yeah.
Yeah, It's crazy.
- [Narrator] You were 14?
I was 14 years old.
My dad died in 2000, 2001.
That's crazy.
So I go.
I opened the door
And then she seen him
laid up against the wall.
Against the door, you know.
And I'm just like fuck.
I just remember just hitting that for him.
And then once my dad
died, it was just like
It was just like
Nobody could tell me nothing.
I ended up going back to jail.
I go back to jail.
Now, now, I'm, I'm, I'm getting older.
My mom's like tripping out on me.
I get out, I get out of jail.
My sister's like, fuck you're changed.
You're different.
You're a gang member now.
Just all this crazy shit.
This shit.
That I was just like
tripping out on like people.
They thinking you're different now
But I got the bus for
so many years, you know?
And everybody's like, Oh,
you're just like your dad.
In and out of jail in and out of jail.
And, and you say, well, geez, you know
but growing up, growing up, it was pretty.
It was, it was hard, you know.
I, I dealt with a lot of shit.
Like when my brothers and
my sisters, they would
they would fuck up.
I get it.
My mom would drink.
She'd get drunk.
And she'd be like, "Hey Dave come here."
I don't know where she just pulled
out the extension cord bro.
And beat the out of me.
And I'm just like, what the fuck?
Like, dude, what the, your problem?
And then I was like
I don't know.
It was like probably like seven years old.
I'll never forget it.
I was at the mall.
I was like seven, maybe
seven or eight years old.
I was already like, I was,
I was already walking behind counters,
taking jewelry out of them, jewelry cases
at the, at the, at the Pasadena
mall with my mom, my dad
and all that.
And everybody, you know, and
getting away with the shit.
But one time I get caught
and I, I get caught.
My mom fucking takes me down.
My dad's is my dad's in the
rest of my mom snatches me up
and she takes me downstairs.
And I remember my mom's telling my dad,
she's going in the car.
And she took me to the car and
I know if she's okay, it was crazy.
And she pulled out the extension cord
and beat the out of me and won't to stop.
I was in the backseat, like
I tried to block and shit.
And then I just remember though
I just remember the side
when the breaking to the car
breaking the window and
my dad slapped my mama.
Snatched her up and put her against him
on the right there by the,
like by the floorboard of the car
and between like the
shifter and telling my mom,
that's the last time
you're going to hit my boy.
And from that day on, she,
she, she never, she stopped.
She didn't stop hitting me.
But after a while it was like,
like she would, it was like
I was already getting, I was like I said
I was getting older and it
wasn't, it wasn't even hurting.
That wouldn't even hurt anymore.
I was like
and then she would try to
like hit me when I was older
like in front of my friends.
And I would push her.
I would, I was bad.
You know what I mean?
Like, like almost blew my mind.
Almost blew my mom's windows
out in her apartment.
I would, luckily I
didn't blow them all out
because we're sitting there making meth.
I was out of control.
- [Narrator] You making what?
I was just making meth.
- [Narrator] For somebody.
- Yeah, at of my mom's house.
This is when I get out.
And my mom's wondering
like with all these buckets
and all these things and all these hoses.
Yeah. This is the I'm like,
I'm already, I'm already older.
I'm like 27, 28 30.
So like, so I'm making
this, I'm making this stuff.
And, and I remember my
my homie pouring this ammonia,
ammonia, nitrate stuff
this liquid into the,
into it's called the pot
and you put it on top and it filters in.
And there's a flask that
you have to take off.
So the pressure, so the
pressure builds up, you know?
And I won't explode, like breathe it.
And I tell him, don't, don't pull so hard.
It's to get, if it doesn't come of, dude
we'll just abandon it.
Foam will go,
Oh, it doesn't want to come off.
I tell him, bro
you got too much condensation
on the inside of.
That shit's not going to come off.
It's a vacuum, bro.
You pull that motherfucker
off and a spark hits.
We're all going out.
And this fool, I know I got it.
I got it.
I told you no use a bottle
with the sprayer and spray it.
So her bottles of water
from the inside falls out
and the steam comes out.
Just let it just rise
out from, just put off.
And it still don't work them off.
So he's like, Oh, just hit it.
And as he hits it, it, it
catches a vapor in the house.
I don't know where the vapor came from.
Probably at a hose that was leaked.
I don't know.
And it flashed, I don't know what it was
but it was a big fireball
to the whole fucking house.
Like, like we were like,
when it went off, we were on fire.
We were fucking, we were on.
And you couldn't even see the fire.
It was like alcohol fire.
Like, you know, you burn it like ethanol.
and you can see the fire
raises into light like that.
I'm on fire.
I'm throwing myself.
And I put myself in the
in the couch and I put to
myself home, burning up.
Mom has his face
all burn up and my
homies like, ah, my arm.
He got the flash.
He got the flashback on that.
When he pulled the thing up, the flash
the liquid from the
inside flashed over float
foamed up like,
if you put seafood in
a pot of boiling water
and you let it sit there,
it's just gonna overflow.
You know what I mean?
So because all the mercury push it all
out just once what it was, what it does.
It just pushed all the
saltwater out of the, out of the
out of the food.
And that's what happened.
And he got him right here
and his skin just licked off.
It was crazy.
- [Narrator] Your arm.
- Not mine.
- [Narrator] His.
- His.
And it, we call it a pinky, you know.
Because his harm Is red like in and out.
Yeah. It took the whole
pigment of his skin off
- [Narrator] What do you call him?
- We call him pinky.
- [Narrator] Pinky?
Yeah.
(laughs)
He doesn't you.
I tell him, Hey, she doesn't
want her dumb to did it.
She thought you were on fire.
I said, so what I used, I got my hands.
He still got his hands
but it's all red bad burn, like real bad.
I tell you where he can see that like
like really you could like
literally drink he moves.
(mumbles)
like you could see the skin
the thickness of the skin and
this, the rest of it's gone.
Like it your de gloved or something.
It was crazy.
It was weird.
But so the cops come,
windows are blown out.
Neighbors, would've stopped blowing out.
I go to jail again this time for
for manufacturing, methamphetamines.
So they tried to get me
on like manufacturing
within the thousand
yards of the school zone.
Oh man, bro charges went from all right.
I'm getting out.
Maybe in about 90 days to six months
to the rest of my life in jail.
I'm like fuck.
For this shit.
For 124 grams you're going to give me life
and all these,
everything that they
found in the apartment
they found bits and pieces.
Because we were already
had, you know what I mean?
Got rid of a lot of stuff.
But they thought enough to,
to basically condemn the house
the apartment until they cleaned it up
for like about a week.
Wow, they, they try to get me for that.
That child's endangerment.
Like okay.
Like 324 charges for that shit.
Because of all the children in school
it was some crazy, odd,
fucking crazy number.
It was like fucking stupid.
And I told him, that's bullshit.
I'm going to fight it.
So I get out on bail, I'm out on bail.
My sister's like, what
the fuck are you gonna do?
I'm like, I don't know.
I'm stressing out, going to court.
And I'm like, it.
I'm just gonna do a speed shot,
Why not?
I got nothing to lose.
So I do a speed trial.
I fucking went down.
she got fired my lawyer
at that time I do my PD.
Well I fired two people so far that two
two PDs so far already,
and now I'm like, home.
I'm going to go from
Bam I get a state appointee.
Wow, I'm like, what the fuck is this?
She's like, Oh yeah.
My name is such and such.
I'm a state appointee from
the state of California.
You're lucky to get one of these.
I'm like a paid lawyer that someone paid
for you that you just
don't even know about.
Just put it like that.
And, and, and they're paying
for you to win this case.
Okay, so you're like a racist,
like just feeling like this.
I'm like a lawyer that like a paid lawyer.
That's some about for you
that you don't even know that.
Just trying to help you out.
So I'm like, okay.
So I'm on bail, right?
So they, they do, they do the
stable and they've all right.
Well, we're gonna come back
to tomorrow where we have
we have, we have reached
fucking all substitute
for tooth SIS section.
She sees the David Sanchez case argued
from Baton was ball is
not, she's not, you know.
So I'm like, Oh.
So we got to come back to court tomorrow.
And like, yeah.
I'm like fuck.
So I'm like, David.
You know, David, David can do anything.
And, and, and a maximum of
we gotta be back in court in 18 hours.
And less than that, well
David's goes on vacation
with his girlfriend.
I'll be in court in the
morning, bright and early.
I'll be good.
Well, I get busted the next morning.
I like, like at seven
o'clock in the morning
for shooting at a car.
Fuck, for shooting at car and Palm dale
I give nothing happens.
Nothing happens.
No cops come the first day.
No cops come.
I fired this car.
All shot all the whole clip.
People are looking at
the windows and I'm like
but they all shut the windows.
No cops, nobody shows up.
I remember the fire.
I fired 10 shots from a nine, from a nine
Two days later, I'm asleep.
Fuck, What the fuck are
you doing in my house?
The SWAT team with the
palm dale PD sheriffs
Broke, went into my
house right in my house.
Oh God.
I heard the doors come open.
I see someone in the hallway over there.
And I was like, what the fuck?
I took my early into the back window
because I already knew what it was.
And I grabbed the shotgun.
I grabbed the gauge that I was
going to throw out the window
And fuck
As I go.
And I get the gauge.
I throw the gauge, I throw it.
It hits the lip of the roof of the house.
I'm thinking, fuck this shit.
gonna fucking fall down.
It's gonna land right there.
And here comes a sheriff running.
I'm like this in the window.
And I finished throwing
the gun and the good
Falls straight into the motherfucking,
straight into the, to the
to where the water runs.
Sits perfect can't see shit.
Boom and I'm like, yeah.
And this is money.
This is a 12 gauge.
It's a nine shot.
Pistol grip,
right edition. Most bird.
This is, this is the right edition.
This is you.
You just don't go find one
of these at any gun stores.
You know, they're, you
can't get nine shots.
They don't make 12 gauge like that.
That's that's an extra,
that's extra, you know
especially automatic where you just it
so that she was a bad-ass 12 gauge.
So I throw it fair cop.
The sheriff runs up.
Don't even fucking move.
And I'm thinking, fuck this
fool, seen me through the gun.
And I'm just like, ah.
Fuck I'm done.
So it take me out the window.
Fucking they handcuff me
and they throw a file in front of me.
I'm thinking, what the is this shit?
And then it was another one in a pictures.
Start to scatter out.
What the fuck is that?
I'm like what the fuck is this?.
A drone 9,000 miles in
the sky took 156 pictures
of the whole thing.
They were already watching my house.
They've been watching my
house for three months,
with the drone.
So they got me on more charges.
And more charges.
I'm looking at,
First day.
First, I go to court first day
to court, you know, you gotta
you gotta get,
preliminary to get run
over your charges and
let you know what you're
being charged with.
So the next time you
come to court that you're
this is what you're going to
be arraigned for, you know.
Well, my first preliminary was
we're offering you 22 years with 80.
The fuck 22 years with 80 am.
And mind you this I'm with my girl.
I got, I got my girl, this
one Karen at the time.
And she, she she's fucking tripping out.
she's fucking
Like fucking
She's going off, but
mind you all this time
I'm sitting there and
she's looking at me like
as we're going to jail, she's
looking at me like, Oh my God
you have these things in the house.
And I'm like, Whoa, hold
on, hold on, hold on.
And then they find the drugs, their purse
but those are her drugs.
And she's like, that's
why you were in my purse.
When they fucking?
Oh dog.
I was like, you was like,
what the are you doing?
And she's like, so you've
been on drugs this whole time.
We could do, we can work to it.
I was like, Oh my God,
this is fucking good.
You're fucking good.
I was like, what fuck the you
talking, what are you doing?
She's like, sir, I had
no idea those were there.
She's like, and, and for him
to put my life in danger,
as I'm sleeping to put them underneath me.
I was like oh fuck,
you're really fucking
blast room, you know.
So the cops like, Oh, you mother fucker.
You're a piece of shit as
a dad oh fucking looking
at the cop, like Dick
you're believing this bitch.
Okay, she gets out of jail first.
I don't know what other reason her
I think your sister bailed her out.
I don't know what it was,
but she got out of jail before I did.
And I'm still fighting this case now.
And, and I'm telling her like
we're on the bus on the way back.
We're on the bus and I'm telling.
She's like, what'd they offer you?
I was like, they offered
me 22 years or 80.
She's like, what the fuck?
I was like, what they ask you?
32 months.
And I go, what the fuck you mean?
She's like, they separated our case.
Why?
cause they bound you over.
And I, what the fuck?
And I, so they fucking railroaded me.
So they, so they know
what the you were doing.
And they just said, all right, it.
This is how we're going to run their case.
We're going to separate them.
For what reason?
Due to her statement, staying
at all, she never know.
So it made me look like I was.
So they were like, all right, it.
She doesn't, she doesn't
really have a record.
We'll break her off a deal.
We'll give her and we'll
let him run his ass
while they fuck it.
Oh man.
I was like, where's your next court date?
I'm going over here.
I'm over here talking.
I'm done.
You got fucking framing.
We go, go back to court.
The DIA offers me, huh?
16 years.
And I'm like, nah, I told her and I wanted
I was like, first off,
where's the gun?
And it didn't Dawn on me.
I was like hold on bro.
I could get out too.
Maybe not right now, but maybe
in about a couple of years.
I could get out.
Maybe in about less than
five years I can get a out.
So I fucking tell the judge.
I tell my fucking order.
Fuck you.
I don't need you.
So I tell the judge, you
know, at this time I'm
speaking now my lawyer's
telling me to shut the fuck up.
I told him, shut the fuck up.
You're fired.
And I tell him, I tell the
judge, you know, record
you know, like, I want to
know where the gun is at.
Yeah, you shows you that it
shows that I was shooting a gun
but where's the gun at no gun,
no evidence, no fucking case.
So I'm like, okay, so we eat too.
He goes, okay, we'll meet.
You goes back.
And the DA's arguing over it.
And they're like, it's
still a violent crime.
You look at these gang members.
I'm like, what was I shooting a camera?
Can't tell it.
Doesn't have no voice.
No nothing can hear it.
It shows me it could be anybody.
It doesn't show that I was
talking to say nothing.
It's like, how can I say it?
It's like, if I show you pictures
of me shooting at somebody
in the car, you can't go off by that.
Yeah.
So it's like, you can't go.
It's just, it's hearsay.
Dismissed.
So I'm like, so that's that charged
from attempt murder goes down to.
Goes down to assault with a deadly weapon.
But where's the deadly weapon.
Dismissed.
Okay he gave me a violation.
My parole head and I'm gone.
So they go from 22 to 16
and I told them, I take
I take eight or half right now.
I will sign for four years right now.
Like 10.
So I did like 10, they
gave me 10 and a half.
I did like a little bit
less than I'm a little bit
a little bit more than a
little bit less than like four.
I was, I was supposed to go home in two.
I could have went home in two.
But then the day I was supposed to pro.
I fucking.
I had to do something.
You know what men.
I just told my sister,
I'm not coming home.
I see you in a couple of years.
I see it two more years.
I had no choice.
You know what I mean?
But it was fucked up and I was like
something you don't want,
ever want it to exist.
You're coming home tomorrow, right?
Just don't expect just, just, yeah.
Just something happened and that's it.
And she's like, you're serious.
You're gonna pull this shit.
You're going to, I, I can't do nothing.
I, I talked to you later, you know?
And fucking she's like, what the fuck?
She's like, I fucking heard
about that shit on the news.
All you guys are prison
are killing each other.
You guys are fucking of the laws.
You so of a bitch.
I don't want to talk to you.
I was like, what the fuck?
And she's like, she's
like, she brought him
in letters and she's
like, you're in the hole.
This that, how long are
you going to be there?
I said, wow, I'll be here for
I don't know, another three years.
So I'm in, I'm in the hole
for like six months now.
24 hours.
I'm losing my mind.
I have no stone interaction with nobody.
I have a cell that's.
I don't know, like.
Like I could walk in here,
like right here, right here.
That's my room.
And then my bed's right here
and the toilets right here.
And you got a little square box, the light
and you got a little walk
me like that and that store.
And that's the wall.
I could stand there and I
could go that I can siren.
Yeah
Just a light and a little,
I got looking chicken.
chicken breeder.
I wouldn't know the light.
How does that
You sleep your toilet is like right here.
They feed you through a hole in the wall.
Five minutes showers.
- [Narrator] How many years
have you gone to prison?
You are how old again?
Your 30?
- 35.
34.
I'm 34.
- [Narrator] 34.
- Yeah,
A lot.
I've done a lot.
Like at least 15 years of my life
in and out and out and out, in.
My mom was like, you're crazy.
You're just, you're just
like your dad, you know.
I've never seen myself like that.
But I was like, I started
noticing like, yeah, I am.
I am like my dad.
I, I, I have his ways, you know.
Then once my dad, like
I said, I'll go back
to once my dad died,
I started stamping heroin again.
I came out here again.
My mom couldn't control me
and my mom was struggling.
Just to get out of the house.
I don't give a shit.
I don't give a fuck.
I started car, I wrecked her car on the
I left her on the train tracks
and blamed it on my brother.
And to this day, my mom
still thinks it's my brother.
Me and my dad blamed that on my brother.
I stole the car.
I went on joy riding and got the car stuck
on the train tracks.
And the car.
I fucking.
I bent the frame.
I was driving the contract.
I was, I was in a movie or some shit.
And I car got stuck.
I call my dad by the train tracks.
He runs down there, what the fuck?
Fucking train stopped right there.
Fucking, you know, I'm
over there hiding and shit
The car fucking pull across the tracks.
They take it back to my mom's house.
And my mom fucking, what the fuck.
I don't know who stole my car
and shit, we're like my brother.
(laughs)
my brother doesn't run now.
And fucking.
It's just crazy.
It was just, I started.
So I came out here
and I used to live
right here on San Pedro.
And I was kicking it with
these people, Mona and Josie
there were big, big
heroin dealers, you know
but I remember her brother being
in federal prison and I'm talking
to him on the phone and
I'm like, what's up?
And he's like, Hey, I don't know you
I'm a federal prison right now.
I'll be out soon.
Just tell us such and such
that you're taking over.
There's no more whatever
you have you give to me
and I'll take care of
the rest of the business.
But from this point forward,
you're fired, you know.
So I fired Dafoe and
he made me his runner.
So I'm running back from heroin
through this little city, you know?
And, and I'm, I'm coming up.
I'm making money.
My mom's ship.
My mom was like, I was shipping out.
Everybody's just like
crazy, you know.
And I get all.
I started getting all fucking depressed
and my dad is nine and my brother-in-law.
So I started slamming heroin again.
And I was with this girl.
I'll never forget.
I was with this girl
and my homies telling me
what the you doing fool?
What the are you doing, dude?
You're going to stab heroin again.
You're going to start up again.
You stopped fool.
I was like, fuck it.
So I snapped.
I, I was like, yeah,
that's what I wanna feel.
Well, I'm out with this
girl, and I'm all fucked up.
And I guess I forget
that I already had fixed.
So the other one.
And I slammed the other one.
After I don't remember nothing
I don't even remember going out.
I remember even sticking it in my arm.
So I'm out in a tent.
A mile and a half body
in the street and inside a tent.
And out of the tent like full light.
Coming up the sidewalk, you know?
Because I'm laid out in the
tent like that in the street.
And my homeboy two shades right there.
Was like seeing the girl
like scattered on her shit, like fast.
And she seen her like
going through my socks
and he was like, what the fuck?
She got up?
She took off running
and he's like, Sharkey,
Sharkey, no answer.
And he's like, what the fuck?
That fool always answer.
No matter what he could be one.
It could be anytime of the night.
I'm not going to answer.
And I didn't answer.
So he went in at 10 and found me out.
I don't know.
I don't even know, but I knew this.
I could hear everything.
I hear everything.
Like, it's crazy.
I can hear everything, but I'm out.
I'm telling myself, wake
up, you got to get up.
I just wasn't getting up.
I just, just, didn't
just didn't have my much
as I tried it just wasn't doing it.
And now I'm sending Shabbat in my head.
Fuck I'm down.
Dead.
I come in here for like, I need to get up
but I just, I just
couldn't, he couldn't do it.
It wasn't happening.
And it's like
I can hear the paramedics
to tell the homie move move.
We got this.
And I remember him fucking
working on me on the ground,
but I, my eyes were open.
I could see him and I'm just looking up.
But I just can't even blame eyes.
I'm fucking, I'm just like
out, but I carry everything
and he's like, they're like,
what'd you, what'd your time.
And he's like, we're at six minutes
or we're at five we're at
five minutes and 48 seconds.
And he's like, we're gonna call it at six.
So at six they kept working on me at six
and there was still nothing.
So, so they started to feel them stop.
And then I'm thinking, what
fuck the are you doing fool?
You stuck in bro.
And then he's like, no, fuck that.
Nah, he's not gonna do this.
And he pumps on my chest
like two more times.
And I wake up.
I trip up.
I wake up.
I get up.
But mind you this, he
cut all my clothes off.
So I get up.
Not knowing what the going on.
I'm freaking out.
I'm tripping out.
Because I don't know what happened.
And I took off running down the streets.
Butt naked.
(laughs)
Running down the street don't
know where the fuck I'm going
but I'm just tripping.
Because I just wake up
and everybody's around me.
So they chased me down the street.
They find me with
discover like tripping up.
What the fuck get away from me.
You know what?
I don't you guys like I'm good.
And they're like, do you know
what you just went through?
It's like, you almost
went through all my self
about seven minutes of no
oxygen to your brain, bro.
He goes, you, I don't know
what you're doing here.
Live breaking your eyes or whatever.
You're doing my hairs huddled up.
But I've been on this thing
for like 18 years, captain chief forever.
I ain't never seen anything like this.
It's like, I don't know
how you're still alive.
It should be like right now
the hospital fighting for life.
I'm like fuck I'm thinking like,
like I still don't get it tripping up.
And I'm like, he's like, I'm
asking you some questions.
And he goes, it's debates if
you go to the hospital or not.
And I was like, I don't have to go, right.
If you answer these
questions, right you don't go.
I'm like, all right, he
goes what's of the sky.
Now, It's like, Like what?
What color is the ground?
Black.
How many fingers I'm I holding up?
Two
10,
I got one more for you.
How many fingers am I holding now?
And I was like fucking two.
It was like, you are fucking lucky.
I was like, what the fuck?
It's like slow.
I was like yeah.
He goes, you're going to feel
like that for a couple of months
or for probably a couple of
days or a couple of weeks.
That's all right.
And then I started noticing
like little things.
Like my leg would drag.
Like I'll walk on.
My leg was just dragging what the fuck?
I was just like, I stutter a lot.
I just told, I just told
myself like, like I gave him
I told him if he gives me
a second chance at life
you only have one guy no more, you know.
But the next day I get high
and the next day I I'm sick, you know?
So I slam again and, and, and I get high
and I'm thinking, here we go again.
I remember throwing up like
the worst shit in my life.
Looking at, at all the heroin
I had and I just throw it
over the fence and I
fucking, and I get busted.
I get busted like a couple
days later and I go to jail.
I stood up for 22 days with no sleep.
- [Narrator] No sleep for 22 days.
- No sleep for 22 days.
For the last 15 days that
I kicked that she stood
in the window of the door
of my cell every hour
of every hour of every
single hour for the kid
for the, before it was like the first one
he was like, I was like, and you're here.
And he's like, damn you've
been here for the last 15 days
in his window.
Exactly on time.
I'm like yeah because I know what time
(laughs)
He's like fuck.
No sleep.
He's like, he was like,
you're looking, you're crazy.
Yeah,
And I remember getting out of jail
and I was like fuck.
I stopped getting out get high.
I was like, I never, haven't got
I'm not going to say having
a high, since I got high
like I broke that 10 years
that I had no heroin.
I was driving home.
Maybe like last year was last
year and a high with my buddy.
My buddy was getting high
with his homie in the car.
And he was like, Hey fool,
you want to get high though?
And I was fool what the fuck
you asked me that question for.
Fool don't do that to me, Dick.
And he's like smell it Dave smell it Dave,
I'm like Dick you are an asshole
for them to do that for him.
So I don't even get hiding.
And I was like, especially
You know, you don't got no shit.
And you know, I'm going to Christmas home.
The fuck for who you why you do that Dick?
And I thought, it.
I'm going to get high for driving.
Anyway.
He's like, nah, Dick don't get high Dick.
I'm just playing with you.
I was like, ah, now you
see you don't get me how
you want me to get high?
Why who crazy Dike?
You trip out.
Like fool don't tell him
what the I'm doing now.
Bought the McDonald's
right here up the street
and I get high.
I fixed one up and I'm like, thinking,
if I do this bunch of
I'm all in fuck that.
So I square like half of it out
I do like maybe like 10 units.
And I'm like, fuck I'm all
over the place in the car.
I'm fucking out of here.
Fuck your don't know.
Don't know how to control shit.
Whatever I did everything.
I touched just fell apart.
Everything, I tried to touch the radio up.
The knob fell off it.
The soda, the soda fell over the car.
I tried to smoke a cigarette
at the street, burn a seat.
And we're tired.
I've been a brand new car, you know?
And he's like, it.
Just stop, stop.
And I'm like, what?
It's just stay still, bro.
Stay fucking still.
And you'll make it home.
I'll be like, all right, Dick.
it up, Dick.
Just leave it alone.
Stay still.
I like Dick.
I'm sorry Dick.
You say started to fall.
We got you fucked up.
I was like fuck you?
And I got home.
I got to this place where I was at.
I don't even remember going in there.
I was so fucked up.
I just, I got out of it.
You know?
Do you use today?
Yeah, I still get high.
Yeah, I still do get high.
I won't sit here and lie to you.
Cause then I wouldn't
be honest with myself.
I can admit that I do have
an addiction, you know.
I do have a problem, you know, but I just
for the meantime right now,
just the way I cope right now
it's about how I cope with my work
where I feel.
The stakes.
Day for day, you know.
You mind if I get another cigarette.
I need water.
Yeah ,you know, it's just like,
it's, it's, it's, it's hard.
You know?
Like my aunt, she tries to help me out.
I figured if I don't change right now
with anybody helping me or
with me being hard at it
and stubborn and me being out here.
I'm going to be dead.
Yeah, It'd be my dad.
I'll be, I'll be dead.
So I figured fuck it.
That's why I moved to over here.
Because it's just too
much over there for me.
It's too hectic.
It's like, I sleep here.
I can relax for here.
I don't have to worry about somebody.
You know what I mean?
Over there.
I'm like, it.
And all I hear is Sharky,
Sharky, Sharky, Sharky.
Like what the fuck bro?
Like I can't even sit down
and take a hit without them saying my name
and the same like what the fuck?
And it's like, everybody's like, not mine.
It's like, I don't like
all the, whatever I have.
I save, bro.
You know, I I'm trying.
I'm telling you.
But then the next three
months that I'm working,
I'm saving up these next
three months of checks.
If I do start working
at this Christmas thing
I'm gonna get her car.
First time we get my apartment.
Because all this SRO get
your free or housing that.
That's the lazy way as you.
Take it as lazy helped me.
If he could pay $30, fuck you.
Fuck 30 down, man.
I'm going to pay 750 or
850 or you pay so much.
I pay $37.
Well that's you because
you got people helping you
and taking out of my taxes motherfucker
You know what I'm saying?
You fucking.
You fucking crack head.
You know what I mean?
That's just coming out of my pocket.
So you know what I mean?
It, just, to me, it's
more of a work ethic.
I think, you know, you, you
work harder for what you get
and you get the better results you work
you don't do shit at all.
What are you going to get?
There's a brownie and a cup of water.
Well, how come he got a fucking double
chocolate chip cookie and milk.
Well, he decided to paint the backdrop.
Not, just spray sparkles all over.
You know.
(mumbles)
(laughs)
- Yeah, you know.
And I have noticed myself
looking at all these cars.
Fuck that motherfucker.
And that's his fucking bullshit.
His fucking family.
Some of them okay, yeah.
They get the in here you go, here you go.
They're spoiled.
But a lot of them it's like,
I'm going to be mad at him.
I'm mad at him because I'm mad at myself.
Because I know can because
I know I could be there
but I just don't want to.
And it's like, why am I mad at him?
He just put a little more.
He put, he put, he
He read the directions on
the, on the, on the box.
And I decided I know
how to put it together.
You know what I mean?
So that's where I went wrong.
You know, he followed the
I'll give him the directions.
And I said, I just look at the pictures.
Why do I have a handful of screws?
(laughs)
Why is it tired over here?
Do you know what I mean?
Crazy shit.
Do some shit like that.
- [Narrator] That's a great plan
Yeah, so that's just, that's that's it.
- [Narrator] Thank you so much
for talking to me.
- Yeah.
- [Narrator] It was really interesting.
How both is it all over the place
- [Narrator] But good
luck with everything.
- Yeah bro.
(mumbles)
- I try not to, you know.
Yeah like here's this chapter of my life.
Yeah.